as reality and nowaday time we can deal
with the fact that um
somebody say we great after 50 or 60
fights
you know um
you had to have 50 fights to get your
first fight in the madison square garden
you had to have 50 fights back in the
20s and 30s you know you fight madison
square garden you have to lose 60 fights
and that's not even a main event
what yeah
say wait i'll say where are you at in
your career after 50 fights huh you got
to be like but listen the reason why
they have so many fights because they
fought so often some guys will fight
four times a month
you know what i mean four times a month
yeah
one got um battling levinsky for three
times in one day in the morning you know
three different states
and won all three fights
15 rounds i believe
20 rounds or something like that that's
crazy it was going to be difficult it
was not crazy
it was just their life is every day
today
you know they got guys that punch real
hard and real slick boxes okay oh he's a
little slick i'm making the round let's
let it go to 45 rounds you're real good
dancer right we're gonna see how long
you can dance
you know that the fighters can do that
they're fighting the guy they know
that's good moving they move good for 15
21 now let's go to the fight to the
finish
let's see let's see how fast you fight
to to just so there's no there's no
distance it took from somebody to fall
the longest fight that went under the
markets of queensberry is 110 rounds the
way we fight today
jack burke and
andy bowen andy bowen was a
guy you know back like a hundred years
ago
they um they identified you with your
race
that's how they identified you so they
would say in this corner the little
mulatto
andy
bowen
and in there the mexican marauder or
something like that you know
they always buy your razor they call it
the black because
the dusky king
or the or the tan terror or something
like that
jack dempsey is the manassa malla from
manassas colorado
they had no recovery time as well they
had no recovery time well listen um
and
can i take andy bowen look up his record
box
this guy didn't have a lot of fights how
many rounds
26 fights but 517 rounds hey
tell him the rounds he went before he
broke the record how many rounds he went
before he broke the record and he
bowling
look how many rounds he went before he
went 110 rounds
[Music]
and he didn't die in 110 rounds he died
in like
20 rounds of of a 80 round fight
80 rounds
i told you he just broke the record for
110 80 nothing to him
seven and a half hours
stuff fighting seven and a half hours
it got so bad they just called it a draw
cause they they couldn't hit each other
because both their arms and finger hands
were broken yeah it says both wrists
were broken yeah they had both of the
fighters everything was broken jesus
[Music]
skin tight glove you know the gloves you
drive when you drive your car yeah they
cuddle yeah they cut them they cut their
fingers off and they put those off it's
basically bad knuckle fighters yeah they
were bare knuckle fighters and this is
the deal
guys that were gloves were considered
[ __ ]
if you walk boxing gloves in the fight
you're a [ __ ]
real men fight bare knuckles
king's rule bare knuckles the king's
rule
and the marcus of queensberry
was a man that was
a man that was a boxing enthusiast
and um
i'm trying to think of a great
author
who was the great author like
1890s
what was his name come on
hey dickens no no it was another one
he was um he was in readings jail
remember you wrote the poem of reading
jail
is that
look at that
democracy queensberry son right who who
started the um wavy fight now
his son who was his son they sent this
guy to jail for having a sexual affair
with his son do you know his name
when do you hear his name everybody
knows his name yeah the mark is the
queensberry son
gustave dory that's his son that's what
i think that's what it's saying right
here who was the marcus of queensberry
sun lover
very famous guy when his name was whoa
him but he sent him to rent in jail
because he was here at that affair with
his son
[Music]
because of that the markets of
queensbury was very powerful
and that embarrassed his reputation i
believe until he get it out for me
what's the name here
real jp more than these guys that fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
one more like that
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again
jab zip roll
[Music]
crosstalk
[Music]
okay
do this
[Music]
[Music]
food
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]